speaking of very real we've got former
National Security Advisor Susan Rice she
told us she feels our democracy is under
assault and the attack is coming from
within she was responding to the
president's call for Ukraine and China
to investigate the bytom Biden family
that was last week this week we were
talking to rice about her more than 25
years in public service including as US
ambassador to the United Nations we met
her across the street from her old
offices in New York she's got a new
memoir it's called tough love my story
of the things worth fighting for it's
published by Simon & Schuster that's a
division of CBS and rice says she wrote
the book right now as opposed to later
to take back control of her life and
career and and define it in her terms
after feeling targeted in what was one
of the most bruising political fights in
memory I was close to President Obama
and he was a target I'm an
african-american woman I don't take crap
off of people and I'm confident in my
own skin putting all that together put
it in a political context of a campaign
and maybe I was an attractive target
Susan Rice says she may never know why
she was swept into the controversy
surrounding the 2012 Benghazi terror
attacks accused by Republicans of lying
about a deadly assault on the US Embassy
in Libya I don't trust her and the
reason I don't trust her is because I
think she knew better and if she didn't
know better she shouldn't be the voice
of America well remember the context
right we'd tragically lost four
Americans including ambassador
Christopher Stevens who was a colleague
and friend of mine for better or for
worse I agreed to be the administration
representative on those five sunday
shows days after that what our
assessment is as of the present is in
fact what it began spontaneously in
Benghazi as a reaction to what had
transpired some hours earlier in Cairo
do you regret doing it yeah the
intelligence she shared on those shows
turned out to be wrong and rice who had
been a front-runner to be the next
Secretary of State felt pushed to
withdraw so you regret going on the show
in part because it stopped you from
achieving
no I regret it mostly because you know I
was what happened as a result of that is
something I was always taught never to
let happen which is to have other people
define me for me but what really hurts
rice says is the toll that Benghazi
episode took honor then nine year old
daughter Maris she was scared she was
seeing images of men coming out of the
walls at her we didn't know what else to
characterize these as then
hallucinations we took her to all kinds
of doctors and were left with the
conclusion that in all likelihood this
was a stress reaction to what I was
going through and we as parents I regret
I think failed to understand that you
know a TV in the background that we are
tuning out a little kid may not that
would make me as a parent I read having
that kind of impact on my child could
say I felt the same not that conflict or
Capitol Hill were new to Susan Rice her
father Emmett was a governor of the
Federal Reserve while her mother Louis
rose to a senior job at the College
Board but while they were Washington's
elite by day by night they were at each
other's throat screaming and yelling and
the throwing of objects got you know
pretty frightening for me and my baby
brother you write that your family was
burning down why did you run into the
fire I didn't know anything else rice
not only survived she thrived
catapulting to Stanford and Oxford and
then the White House first as a member
of Bill Clinton's National Security
Council before joining the Obama
administration has the presidency of
Donald Trump and worse than expected far
worse than I ever could have imagined
far worse and yet you're hopeful I'm not
hopeful about this president or his
policies I'm desperately concerned to be
as Frank as I can what I'm hopeful about
is America's capacity to grow and change
and to renew itself these days part of
that renewal is happening at Rice's own
dinner table her son Jake is a young
Republican while her daughter MERIS is a
teenage progressive and while they often
disagree she says
they're always a family what makes us
able to hang together is that we realize
that family is so much more important
than our political or policy differences
and so in the same vein Americans need
to understand at the end of the day
we're in this boat together we get two
choices it's like we talked about
earlier knock down the others stay down
or you get back up I also asked if she'd
want to serve as Secretary of State if
the next president is a Democrat and she
told me she would be open to it it's so
interesting to hear her talk about her
daughter and you realize the human cost
of the toxic political dialogue that we
have when you hear stories like that I
mean that's just devastating absolutely
and you know I want to say I knew her
public persona which is pretty tough in
Graaf I knew she was a policy expert
this memoir is very good as a family
story families are complicated hers more
complicated than most madami we saw that
picture of her parents and we all
commented oh what a great-looking couple
in your next line whoa
humanize her because you look at
officials like that and you forget they
have families they have backgrounds but
she's overcome a lot and it's survivable
that's the thing you know family chaos
you can't get through it
is that a remarkable career